many things to talk about in this first
portion of today's friday show first i
want to follow up on a story from
earlier this week earlier this week we
talked about
former fox news host bill o'reilly
absolutely losing it at an airport
treating jetblue employees terribly
because their flight to turks and caicos
was running very very late well the man
who
supports the party of personal
responsibility and supports taking
responsibility and holding people
accountable for their actions he says
really this is biden's problem
and it's because of biden that he
flipped out on a uh on a worker at the
airport as a reminder let's start with
the original clip this is bill o'reilly
at jetblue in jfk airport threatening to
get a worker fired and demanding his
name and aggressively leaning towards
the guy and all
[Music]
listen flight delays suck it's not the
gate agent's fault like i said you don't
treat people like this and now he starts
with the threatening for losing your job
is
[Music]
you're going to lose your job so anyway
that was the incident and now we have an
explanation from bill o'reilly
and uh he's blaming biden i don't know
guys maybe there's something to it
bill o'reilly says it's biden's fault he
threw a fit and
the statement is on tuesday o'reilly
tweeted the character assassins on
social media are completely lying about
my interaction with the jetblue guy who
misled passengers during a five-hour
delay i expected this speaking to
mediaite o'reilly acknowledged that he
handled the situation poorly
and could have used different words but
refused to apologize he claimed numerous
people recognized him and they started
asking him about the hold up he almost
became like a union rep guys so bill
o'reilly was just speaking for the
people that's what was going on he
insisted the heat on him is a
distraction from the real story which is
that jetblue is subpar the story is
jetblue can't get their flights off the
ground it was crazy in the terminal
um for some reason the biden
administration is not big on solving
problems and this is a huge problem how
this has to do with joe biden i truly
have no idea and the story here remember
there's two stories here
one story is they say they're all about
personal responsibility
when they do something when they choose
to behave a certain way
and it's horrible and they get called
out they blame somebody else and of
course secondly it's
they always insist in political
discussions you must state your
principles give me your list of
principles here and one of the
principles is personal responsibility as
soon as the principles are inconvenient
they ignore the principles they abandon
the principles and that's the way it
works and as i said before and i'll say
it again
i have been
so frustrated some of the most
frustrating situations i can remember
relate to airlines once
my flight was just canceled there was no
reason wait but so is there a technical
problem no
is there a weather problem
no
the flight has been cancelled
never an explanation i lost a day but
that we're rebooking you tomorrow
you want to start screaming at people
but you don't because you realize it's
not this person's fault and my guess
when o'reilly says that they were being
misled i know that feeling it's very
common when you fly that they say uh
folks
we uh have just there's a light on
that's on the plane and we want
maintenance to look at it
it's just gonna be ten minutes until
they get here so we're gonna hold off on
boarding for now okay well ten minutes
go by and they say we're we're still
waiting for maintenance and finally
maintenance gets there but they said it
was 10 minutes for maintenance to get
there they didn't say anything else so
maintenance has uh identified a problem
and we're going to look for a part here
and if we get it it's only about an hour
fix once we find the part okay
45 minutes go by
we've not been able to find the part it
is an hour fix once we find the part but
this actually happened to me in las
vegas they said the closest part right
now is in san diego we found the part
and it's only an hour to install it but
it's coming in on a san diego flight
that flight leaves san diego in a half
hour very short flight but now you're
doing math you're going okay wait so
we're already 75 minutes delayed
the flight doesn't leave for 45. then it
takes 45 and then they got to get the
part and then it's another hour and then
and then you get to now fortunately this
didn't happen to me but then the classic
is our our crew has timed out they now
are mandated to rest which i have no
problem with we want everybody to be
rested i don't want unrested crew and
pilots flying
and then you lose a day i mean listen i
i get it these things are frustrating
you don't start treating people like
crap that's really the principle we
should all be sticking to bill o'reilly
blaming everybody but himself
i have a clip for you today
that is one of the most dangerous clips
i can remember
ever playing on this program and the
reason it's dangerous isn't because the
person in the video candace owens
is uniquely dangerous herself there's if
you go on the new york subway platform
right as as i often do you see
unhinged people saying wacky things
they're yelling them sometimes they're
yelling at no one but they're not
dangerous because no one's paying
attention to them
if the crazy subway guy
i don't mean that jared guy from subway
the commercials i mean the new york
subway if the crazy new york subway guy
had a million people following them on
social media
and 150 or 200 or 300 people paying to
hear them speak we would say wow that
subway guy is really dangerous
that's the case with candace owens
in this clip now remember candace owens
falsely claimed that the comedian bob
saget probably died from the covid
vaccine
he died from a hit to the head okay
here she is saying she believes they
they
intentionally killed people in hospitals
during covet
and people clap and people nod and
people agree
well i am a big believer that they
intentionally kill people in hospitals
during copay they wouldn't now who is
they okay so let's take let's pretend
that this
these claims were subjected to actual
standards first is candace who is they
is it the nurses is it the doctors is it
hospital administrators did some kind of
covert government operatives infiltrate
the hospital and sneak around and the
nurses didn't notice and they
who is they let family members in there
to make decisions for them i personally
saw when i went to an asthma clinic that
they would not give me life-saving
asthma treatment because breathing was
not allowed even though they had the
nebulizer breathing was not allowed
um
candace who didn't allow breathing
and how did you survive if you weren't
allowed to breathe
um and if they had not sent an ambulance
i mean asthma attack is about like
you've got a very short window of time i
was having an asthma attack and the
doctor had the life-saving medicine and
said that the cdc had barred them from
giving it to me so there was no question
that they colluded to kill american
citizens so that they could fluff
numbers and say that people died of
cobid i do i still to this day question
the use of ventilators it makes entirely
no sense people need oxygen not
compression on their chest when they're
dealing with something that's in their
chest now of course a ventilator doesn't
deprive you of oxygen um so from top to
bottom yes our government wants people
to die there's no question now
understand that there's often a conflict
with a lot of these conspiracy theories
she says
they were they were killing people to
fluff up kova death numbers
others say
the numbers are just bogus the numbers
are invented out of thin air and of
course there's a conflict there right
because
if the numbers are just invented out of
thin air to make the death seem high why
would you need to go in and kill people
in order for them to be really dead and
reported as coveted deaths because
they're just making up the numbers you
don't need both it's a conflict it
doesn't matter uh because it fed the
narrative yeah and and it it's a it's
the we're talking about crimes against
humanity people should face uh long
prison sentences people people should
face tribunals because of what they did
tribunals what are you talking about
during covet
and not even that the masking of
children the treatment of special needs
kids that were being forced to be masked
on planes that were having um you know
essentially the trauma that was put
people on a psych on a psychological
level uh right he's now speaking to the
emotional trauma yeah he should bring
forth tribunals uh people like bill
gates and dr fauci should be in prison
rachel valencia what what
what crime did bill gates commit he
among them this was corruption top to
bottom
and it was all done because they had
already predestined the vaccine right
they did denied treatment they denied
the use of hydroxychloroquine now now
remember
if this was subjected to actual rigor we
would say what evidence do you have that
hydroxychloroquine works for treating
kovid and she would either not know or
she would say i don't know there's the
35 person study from france or whatever
and we would say well we have randomized
controlled trials we have really good
rand we have proper science and it shows
that it doesn't work now she says
ivermectin
yeah same thing with ivermectin what
evidence do you have that divermecton
works for coven there is none that is
randomized controlled trials they say it
doesn't work
um but it's it's it's diarrhea of
dishonesty
uh the media was complicit in it and it
infuriates me it infuriates me the
amount of people that were allowed to
die and to suffer when there were
medicines that worked because they knew
that they could not get emergency use
authorization if there was all right
so you know you hear stuff like this and
remember
people who believe this stuff sit on
juries i've told my story of when i when
i had jury duty on my 21st birthday
and
it was appalling
it was appalling that it was a simple
self-defense assault case
and a third of the jury did not even
understand the law
it wasn't about we disagree about the
facts it wasn't about we have different
opinions about who's credible
a third of the jury
didn't understand the law that was
supposed to be adjudicated
used to adjudicate the facts of the case
so the people who believe oh the
ventilators deprive you of oxygen or
they killed people
these people are on juries they teach
school
they might be your dentist they might be
your accountant i don't know but but
more critically you know if they're your
dentist and you don't like them you get
a different dentist you can't choose
your jury
you only to some degree can choose your
kids teachers or whatever the case may
be these people are extraordinarily
dangerous and um they have followers
and it's absolutely horrifying i told
you recently that it was a really bad
launch for cnn plus cnn plus is the
streaming wing of cnn
under 10 000 viewers a day the david
pakman show is dramatically bigger than
cnn plus and they spent is it tens or is
it hundreds of millions of dollars on it
it's crazy and just like that cnn plus
is shutting down not even a month in
warner brothers discovery is shutting
down cnn plus as of april 30 marking one
of the company's first significant
maneuver since completing the merger of
warner media and discovery less than two
weeks ago this puts an end to cnn plus
this decision is in line with wbd's
broader direct to consumer strategy said
chris licht the incoming ceo of cnn in a
complex streaming market consumers want
simplicity and an all-in service which
provides a better experience and more
value than standalone offerings i don't
think that's the case
i talked about this on a stream
we
lit little old us and our colleagues in
independent progressive media
we are not
part of a network we are not part of a
coordinated marketing strategy and yet
we have plenty of both audience that is
larger than cnn plus and audience
crossover the fact that if people want
to watch me
and then sam cedar
and then the young turks and that you
know whatever else right
we're
you can find us on youtube we have
youtube channels but you know our
podcasts are in different places we have
all different schedules when you call in
is completely different
and people watch all of the shows they
don't they don't need everything to be
an all-in all-in-one solution and i
think what the problem is that
cnn plus tried to capitalize generally
on the growth of streaming which may no
longer be growing i mean consider that
netflix saw a loss of subscribers for
the first time in history
that we may be reaching saturation at
this point in time but cnn plus wanted
to jump in generally on the popularity
of streaming
but they weren't bringing
known content in the sense of like
netflix and amazon prime at least you go
oh here's 10 shows i love i already love
them they're all there
with cnn plus it was original content
um on a platform that nobody had any
emotional connection to not that
everybody's emotional connection to me
is so positive right we have a lot of
haters but the idea here is well people
are in the audience because they want to
hear from me our team us our guests the
callers the community there was
absolutely no community aspect to cnn
plus the technology wasn't innovative or
notable
it's just it's just a dud there's no
other way to say it and we'll see if
some of these other services end up
going the same way it doesn't bring me
pleasure
but it makes me
reassured that
it is not a clear you know everybody
likes to have a hot take about what the
future is early on the legacy tv people
were saying this streaming thing is not
going to take off well they were wrong
then the streaming people said we're
going to have indefinite growth and
first mover advantage will prevent
netflix and amazon prime for ever having
any issues and growth started slowing
down and competitors entered the market
and you've got apple tv with ben
stiller's great show and all these
different things and so actually they
were wrong too
um there there's no one
path forward and i think the takeaways
are flexibility
genuine content and putting the
connection with the audience ideally
first rather than saying we're cnn we'll
just put a plus sign after it and people
want rand will want random shows our
friend rex chapman former nba player he
had
i hope that i'm right
he had or might continue to have i don't
know i saw some of what he was doing on
cnn plus it's cool i but i already know
rex and so that's the advantage and
everything about it was approached in a
way that that didn't really make sense
and it's over it's already being shut
down april 30th and think of the money
that was spent and again i've said this
before
if we got a cash infusion that was just
five percent of what was spent on cnn
plus
we
10x what we're doing i mean we take the
content that we've developed over time
which we know has led to a decade of
growth right we've never had a year
where we shrink we every year we grow
more than a decade 15 years
and we just dump that content in front
of tons of people by buying google ads
and youtube ads and twitter ads and all
this different stuff
we j we don't try to reinvent the wheel
we just say let's put what we're already
doing that works in front of more people
and uh it would have been money much
better spent giving us five percent of
what it cost to launch cnn plus would
have been a much a much better
investment let me know your thoughts
about the new streaming wars
the at least temporary decline of
netflix the end of cnn plus all of it
find me on twitter at deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpackman.com
the david pakman show is of course a
viewer and listener community supported
program we don't have a money tree we
don't have a coin plant in the backyard
or anything like it we depend on you
and you can sign up at joinpackman.com
you can also if you have a membership
already you can now gift a membership to
somebody else there is a box that you
will see
that says is this a gift and if the
answer is yes you just check the box if
you don't know who to gift a membership
to don't worry we have a list of nearly
700 people waiting for free memberships
you can also request a free membership
at davidpakman.com
free membership
let's speak to some of these great
people members and non-members alike we
take calls on fridays via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to alex from
baltimore alex go ahead
hey david can you hear me yes i can
cool
um i got a question about um
i got a question about um publicly
funded elections sure so
i know it's a long shot in the united
states but uh
so hypothetically if one were to happen
how does the money get doled out
because
i know
you know if it's a governor or president
technically there's like eight
independents and a bunch of other random
parties no one's heard of so do they get
a share of the money or is it do they
have to meet a certain qualification
again this is a great question this is a
great question so listen there's no one
way to set this up but you could you
could establish so what do we mean by
public funding of elections the idea is
to limit the amount of money that can go
into an election
and
it and i have to say it's so loud where
you are alex would it be okay if maybe i
mute you to answer because it's this is
a very important issue
uh hang on can you hear me better right
now yeah i can hear you fine it's just
there's so much background noise so the
way we would set it up would be we might
say okay
once you meet a certain signature
threshold
then you qualify and it can't be like
300 signatures right it really has to be
significant so you don't have 100 people
then you get x amount of money
you get x amount of local television
time and whatever you could do it on a
polling basis you have to be polling at
least x percent now some people will say
well the problem is you need money to
get the polling and it okay but so
that's that's another way that it could
be looked at you also might have
different thresholds depending on the
population of the state or the race that
you're you're running so you wouldn't
necessarily expect uh you know a senate
candidate and a congressional candidate
to have the same thresholds in terms of
signatures at least because one is
drawing from a much larger population
base so there's not one answer to the
question but it's a really important
question that has to be crystal clear
when you put these systems in place
okay cool yeah i figured that was the
end i also didn't know is there any
examples of other places that do it
you i don't have any offhand to be
perfectly frank
interesting yeah let me research that
let me just do one more quick i promise
sure um
what is your
guilty pleasure foods the thing that's
just greasy and nasty and no nutritional
value but it's delicious and you tear it
up every time man i i don't know greasy
and nasty i avoid foods i consider nasty
you know well i i mean like looking
tasting i i don't i don't know i mean
you know what cheesesteak that's all
spread out you know it looks a certain
way yeah i know i'm not big i mean i
think you know the the argentinian slash
italian chicken dish milanesa which is a
fried chicken cutlet i am a big fan of i
guess that would be considered greasy
although i don't have it very often i
guess i could also say what about like a
dessert like something that's overly
ridiculously sweet i'm a big uh i'm a
big tiramisu guy
that's not a bad choice yeah all right
that's all i had thanks for taking my
call alex quick question would you agree
that the top desserts are
tiramisu
flan
uh chocolate lava cake and pistachio
baklava do you agree with that take
um you have a very mediterranean take on
desserts don't you
um i'm
i'm kind of a good old american boy when
it comes to desserts oh please don't
bring up apple pie if you bring up apple
pie we're gonna have to cut it off uh
let me meet you in the middle then how
about a key lime pie okay
that's less obvious overtly offensive
i'm more of a tart sweet guy so it's
things like apple pie lemon meringue
that kind of stuff all right well we'll
agree to disagree my friend thank you
yes very respectfully of course see
people can have differences of opinion
and still communicate
in a respectful way let's go to royland
from uh grand rapids roiland you're on
the air
david nice to hear from you man it's
nice to hear from you thank you
yeah yeah
um so i had a question about uh modern
monetary theory sure
um
i don't know if you knew last year uh
john yarmoth represented from kentucky
was on c-span kind of touting a
modern monetary theory and you know
accepting it as like a lens and
framework to view kind of like the
government and how it spins sure so
i was curious um do you think that mmt
will like kind of become more prominent
and more and more mainstream i obviously
mainstream's kind of hard to choose but
you know more of a promoted prominent
framework to view policymaking
here's the thing about modern monetary
theory a lot of people um think about it
like something that you enact
like okay we we now we've turned on
modern monetary theory now there's
modern modernity it's not really it's
really a perspective right the idea of
mod the fundamental idea of modern
monetary theory
is that um
currency need not be
restricted in order to prevent inflation
in absolute terms and that the creation
of new money by governments
has
varied effect
depending on what the money is spent on
and if you spend the create created
money because we're talking about ones
and zeros at this point if you spend or
allocate the created money in certain
ways it can be economically stimulative
whereas allocating that money in other
ways
might cause inflation so it's it's not
something where it's like we're now
doing modern monetary theory it's really
just a framework where we would think
about government spending in a different
way does that make sense
yeah i agree i think the issue right now
is kind of because something like uh the
clinton years where we were in uh i
think a
def i forget what they call it a deficit
of some kind
where there was less money in the uh
economy um trying to get away from that
framework because obviously we love the
clinton years but we shouldn't be really
uh having our our balance sheet in that
direction where there's less money in
the actual economy uh so i feel like the
democrats in particular would have to
reframe their arguments on modern
monetary theory but um
as stephanie kelm has said with in her
recent interviews that i've seen
actually i'm not sure how recent they
are but she's actually talking to like
senate or uh to budget committee members
and everything so it's like they they
understand it but they almost feel like
they're trying to figure out how to
um reveal it to the general public
yeah i mean i i just the the concept can
be boiled down pretty simply which is
like government spending doesn't just
diminish the value of the dollar and
cause inflation we need to actually look
at what the money is being spent on and
it can actually have economically
stimulative effects i mean it's sort of
like taking elements of demand side
economics and adding more of a fiscal
policy currency aspect to it i don't
know the best way to communicate it but
uh i do think that
because elements of it are correct
it will hopefully become more of a part
of the discussion going forward is my
hope
yeah my hope my hope is that for too
because when you read articles about
modern monetary on just whatever
websites they're always saying like oh
this is what we tried for the stimulus
package and look it's not working as
well the thing is like did they actually
discuss uh any of these policies with
any modern monetary theorists about you
know controlling inflation and
unemployment and all that the answer is
no they just consider any of that yeah
so well very good i appreciate the call
yeah definitely if you can just have
some more mmt people uh interviewed that
would be great for it to become in more
public yeah we've had stephanie kelton
on twice and am i right that pavlina
cerneva also is an expert on mmt i'm
trying to remember i think she might be
um i am unaware my guys would be like
rohan gray and warren mosler obviously
and randall ray those are the main three
guys that i would list i listen to but
all right we will look into it thank you
awesome thank you so much you have a
great rest of your day you too there is
roylan with a beautiful phone call
let's go to pablo from albuquerque new
mexico i've never been to new mexico
pablo
hi david can you hear me yes i can
all right great um yeah so um
i'm not sure i really have a question
it's more
a while back you had asked um
why we should keep on bringing up uh
about the deaths of like right-wing
conservatives
and it's sort of touching on that um
wait hold on a second i asked
why should we bring up the deaths of
conservatives
uh sorry yes in regards to um covet
deaths okay um
or um
why um
uh
pretty much like when all these um let
me see if i can under so you're saying
sometimes an anti-vaccine right-winger
gets coveted and dies
and i said
part of the reason to bring it up is
that it exposes the incredible hypocrisy
and also futility of their perspective
when they confidently say no one needs
to be vaccinated and then they die and
hopefully it'll encourage other people
to get themselves vaccinated is that
more or less what you're talking about
yeah more or less and um
i the reason why
um
i think uh is
um
as you said it
just
uh you have to
they're confronted with oh well you know
this um
everybody was saying uh people on the
right conservatives were saying oh you
don't need a vaccine look you'd be fine
you don't have to wear a mask especially
the mask um
being uh mandate not being uh required
on planes
um it does confront them with their own
um
uh sort of beliefs um actually uh
there's somebody that joe rogan uh
interviewed on his uh podcast megan
phelps rogers who is
roper
roper yes i've interviewed her as well
okay um i hadn't seen that one i was
actually curious about that but um
yes and uh you know she mentioned how
exactly
being part of the westboro baptist
church uh she had a there's somebody
that kept on confronting her about all
these ideas that she had and it was a
lot harder for her to
once she was politely confronted with
all these different ideas she sort of
had to come to grips with that a lot of
it didn't make sense to herself yes
absolutely well said thank you pablo
all right thank you david all right yes
let's confront people politely when they
have incorrect ideas let's take a very
quick break we are going to take more
calls in a moment so don't hang up if
you're hanging on to talk to me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow let's go back to the
phones via discord
davidpakman.com slash discord
let's go next to eric from cancun eric
welcome back
eric from cancun you're on the air if
you can get your audio working
and last chance for eric from cancun
plagued
with corrosive
technical difficulties
all right no eric from cancun today
not a problem let's go uh next
to
cody from san diego how is san diego i
was there not long ago love the weather
great restaurants
hey david can you hear me yes i can uh
it's pretty great down here in san diego
you know good pretty pretty good weather
um
i didn't uh i kind of had a just a
scenario i
wanted to comment on um it's kind of
like
just accepting just being a dumer and
accepting uh that republicans
very well may win in 2022 and
looking forward to 2024
if
likely scenarios keep on happening and
they win then as well um what's
what what do you think the climate looks
like i mean back in
2016
kind of the narrative around uh that i
was hearing um back then was
it whether trump or hillary wins it's
kind of like
not necessarily going to affect the
daily lives of the middle class um and
uh like we kind of see some of the
repercussions now do you think it's
going to be
like very
like incremental repercussions type of
thing or is it going to be
kind of drastic swing changes that we'll
see
uh take place um
right away uh if a scenario like that
would happen just wanted to i don't know
that i understand you're saying if
republicans take the house and senate in
the midterms how radical will the change
be is that what you're saying
yeah yeah in the midterms and then also
if that compounds into them taking the
white house in 2024. 2024 is too far
away to say because it that's a few
layers away
here's the things that will change very
quickly if republicans take the house
and senate in november
first of all
no bills are getting passed so you know
biden did infrastructure he did a
coveted stimulus bill you know there's a
number of different bills that were
passed
nothing is going to get done nothing it
just there will be nothing done for two
years except you know if there is the
most dire emergency where the congress
absolutely has to do something they're
going to do it but it will basically be
two years of obstructing joe biden in an
even more overt way than is being done
right now number two yes probably there
will be house investigations into joe
biden and hunter biden and they may even
impeach him and they will very quickly
make the united states a joke again the
way it was under um donald trump so i
think that
you know when we say well the middle
class won't really be directly affected
uh well i guess that remains to be seen
but our
the reputation of the united states will
very quickly go into the toilet again as
a laughing stock so
it remains to be seen how quickly they
will do these things but they will do
them and unfortunately i do think
they're going to win in the fall
yeah yeah and that's the scenario i see
as well but yeah um just to kind of
compound on you on your point do you
think
what do you think the tangible um
i guess repercussions of a joe biden
impeachment would be
well i don't think it would remove him i
think it would just be remember the
impeachment is what the house does and
then the senate would either convict or
acquit i don't think that that he would
get convicted because he didn't do
anything wrong
and so that's that's a factor even with
republicans having a slight majority in
the senate i don't think that joe biden
gets convicted on impeachment i think it
will just become a charade it will
become a distraction and it will just
build the the humiliation of the united
states globally
yeah well i appreciate your comments
thanks all right cody from san diego
thank you keep enjoying the uh the good
weather there
let's go
next
to
um
let's go to it's hi
from copenhagen denmark
hi david it's good to be on it's a
pleasure to have you
yeah um i wanted to ask you um what are
the odds that given the democratic
presidential candidate in 2024 wins the
electoral college and the republican
candidate refuses to concede
that the republican-controlled congress
will overturn the election and make
uh said republican candidate the next
president of the u.s
so that that's a that's a really good
question so let me let me restate the
scenario so people understand it
um
some democratic candidate wins the 2024
presidential election maybe it's biden
maybe it's someone else they win they
get more electoral votes they are
supposed to be the next president
however
republicans let's imagine control both
the house and the senate could they
successfully prevent the winner from
becoming the president of the united
states my instinct itai
is to say no it wouldn't happen they
don't really have the power they tried
to take that power some of them did in
2020 they don't really have the power so
there's no way in hell that they prevent
the democratic winner from becoming the
president that's my instinct
but then i think about well hold on a
second
even in 2020
they weren't close but they were close
to making it tough
and so if they were in full control
what would happen and then i start to
get a little bit scared
let's hope the former case is true
i also wanted to ask you um what topic
would you like to be taught in public
school that would make um the american
public more politically aware and
engaged
uh critical thinking and media literacy
ah that's good i um
i would have picked um
a course on political ideologies so
people at least know what the different
terms actually mean yeah
i see that as only really being useful
if everybody already is educated in
critical thinking and media literacy i
see those as previous prior steps to
jumping into political ideology but i
don't disagree with you
i see
um
i also um wanted to suggest that you
should um
cover less the hate mail that you get
be it chats and from voicemails it's
because we already know that you are
getting it but um
i mean i mean it's it's a given uh i
would suggest it unless it's
constructive criticism to just ignore it
because it's yeah it's not worth your
time so listen i understand that um we
do uh on fridays in the last segment we
do 10 minutes of emails and usually
there's like two that are negative so
it's like 10 minutes
on one show a week and it's only one or
two of those minutes so i i understand
the opinion it's a really small part of
what we do
oh i see um that was me um
how is yeah here in denmark just uh so
your audience knows the covet pandemic
is
um soon over there are still some cases
but
uh we don't wear masks or anything okay
yeah there's really no masks in the in
the us either hey real quick can you
very slowly
pronounce copenhagen the way you do in
denmark because i struggle to understand
how you guys pronounce it can you say it
once slowly for me
in danish or english in danish
it's because the er
is a sound that doesn't uh exist in
english okay and say say it one more
time slowly for me
wow so that so that
the g really disappears
um yeah it does it does it's more of a v
sound got it got it
all right very good thank you i
appreciate the call
thank you david and have a nice day you
too there's itai from
copenhagen is the way i say it okay
let's go uh let's go next where are we
going next it's it's just it's hard to
know
um
because the phone calls are so
widespread let's try going to southcat
southcat you're on the air oh
southcat oh my goodness hello david
oh are you
scottish no australian oh australia oh
okay sorry i misheard your accent
initially welcome
thank you so much uh yeah a lot of
people
probably expect me to sound like
crocodile monday with a shrimp on the
barbie but no
um well thanks for taking my call i just
um
i just went to i was having a chat to
somebody
recently
um
about
well he he
his thoughts were that the buildback
better plan um
had an effect on
uh inflation
like
a market of
what from what i believe
quite a bit of an effect on inflation
and i thought
i didn't necessarily agree with that but
what are your thoughts if you
no i don't think so inflation uh has
been inflation predates the
infrastructure package passed by joe
biden and it also is global including
you know affecting countries that have
nothing to do with american
infrastructure spending so i've seen no
evidence that that is the case
well thank you for that um
i yeah i appreciate it i hope hopefully
he might be listening um and just
another thing i just want to say i
really appreciate your
the forensic nature in which you comment
on
words
the rhetoric that
people in the media uh
whoever they are over a broad respect
spectrum it's really
important um words matter you know
i appreciate that very much
uh yeah
south cat thank you listen is it is it
like 1 30 in the morning in australia
right now what time is it there it's uh
it's 2 40 i'm doing
uh
yeah a bit of work it's the middle of
the night
is it the middle of the night yeah
actually no to 2 40 a.m right yeah a bit
of night owl when i have to get a lot of
work done so
but um oh and one more thing i just just
one quickly um i also appreciate you
mentioning the
situation with healthcare um especially
with i i saw that i think it's kentucky
have banned abortion yeah i'm not sure
sorry um this is disturbing um i i
really feel
bad about it
so
hopefully uh things will get better yeah
all right southcat you've said it all
thank you so much for the call
thank you david thank you very much keep
up the good work my pleasure thank you
there is southcat from australia the
middle of the night the witching hour
as some uh as some might call it all
right let's go to isaiah from arkansas
isaiah welcome back to the show
hey david can you hear me yes i can
hey so um i just have a little question
i'll have to explain a little bit but
the um question is
um
do you think that it's actually possible
for politicians to represent the will of
the people and kind of what i mean by
that is
that's just one example
in ireland right now the same poll you
have a majority of people that say we
want to join nato yep and in the same
poll same group a majority of people
oppose
abandoning neutrality
so that's a fundamentally contradictory
idea yeah so your question is actually a
different one you're quite so you're
you're this is interesting you're asking
the question as
can politicians really represent their
constituents but the real question is
can politicians actually know what their
constituents want that's fundamentally
the question you're asking that's kind
of what i'm what i meant like yeah let's
say i'm running for office and
i'm not i'm way too young for that but
you know i
you know
am not
particularly informed about an issue
trying to learn trying to figure out
like hey what do the people in my state
want right when you have contradictory
ideas
i think that that this is a solvable
problem now i understand how if you join
nato you're no longer neutral so how
could you want both to be neutral and to
join nato that's a really specific
example let me let's let me argue
that
for the most important domestic issues
it's much easier to understand what your
constituents want and so i i do think
that that's a solvable problem but i
agree that with something like foreign
policy particularly because a lot of
people don't know what's going on it can
be hard to ascertain what people
actually want you to do that's fair but
i think with the bulk of issues we can
get pretty good data about what people
want
yeah well like to tie it to like a
domestic issue which i was trying to
stay away of from but like with
universal health care right a majority
of americans polled say they support uh
universal health care which i do as well
but a majority of americans also oppose
paying for health care through taxes
right yeah that's a that's a conflict
and that that's that one is very complex
because
you can even ask
that second question about taxes in
different ways and get dramatically
different answers so it's not even as
it's actually even more complicated than
you're pointing out but uh point taken
you're raising an important issue
yeah and i have two two little side
things one
i'm actually
um i want your opinion on this going to
uh florence and rome in italy in a few
weeks okay
perk
um
for for a class of mine i was wondering
if you have um will kind of be going all
around the city are there in
have you been to either of those two
cities and are there
special food items you would encourage
me to try well i've never been to
florence but i have been to rome i mean
honestly just stay away from the tourist
traps if they have like multi-colored
menus in eight languages and someone
suggesting you eat there don't go there
but there's so many great great uh
places
in uh there there's one place that's
basically known for
uh
cod fritters
in rome i forget the name of it i think
it's like fileto de bacalao or something
like that i would absolutely go there uh
there's a place called uh macedoni it's
kind of kind of like sounds like the
word macaroni in english
and uh it's also another great little
spa i mean it's just stay away from the
tourist traps you really can't go wrong
in rome
okay yeah thank you and before i uh
before you let me go i just want to say
um i really really appreciate
you among all the
uh broader however you define yourself
uh political punditry um in just how
honest you've been with specifically
things in regards to ukraine
i've been very very disillusioned with a
lot of the west and a lot of creators i
formerly had a risk
formerly respected and in retrospect
have had to
go look back at their contact yeah
content and it's
really it's really really disillusioned
me without with a lot of stuff so i
really appreciate
your coverage of it in your honesty all
right isaiah i appreciate the
compliments i am going to let you go and
hope to hear from you again soon and
enjoy italy
that's going to do it for today we will
take calls again we'll take a quick
break and be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
my friends it is time for the friday
mailbag you can email info at
davidpakman.com if you have something
you'd like to say sometimes tweets or
youtube comments or instagram comments
may be included as well
don't abuse info at davidpakman.com it's
not good for you and it's not good for
me either
let's just jump in with the first
message this one is from charles
charles
is writing about the hunter biden laptop
and charles says well
since the laptop has been deemed real
why don't you look into it and then say
it's not a big deal i almost feel bad
for the cuckman i think that's me he
goes through his whole life thinking he
is intellectually capable david pakman
is the cuckman he makes his wife's
boyfriend a sami
after he slays her and thanks her for
the opportunity to watch him and will
smith should hand out they can be a good
support system for each other both are
cucks both of their wives have public
relations with others
this is the level
of people who want to decide
who else is intellectually capable now
as we've said before
we've talked about the hunter biden
laptop story
the story is filled with misinformation
and also has nothing to do with joe
biden so to the extent that
the story
is a media story we've talked about it
but that's about as far as i'm
interested in going with the hunter
biden laptop
polar wrote in
and said when most people look at david
pakman they just see a dude when
conservatives look at david pakman they
somehow detect foreign-born
jewish
east coast urban dweller and most
offensively of all
most offensively of all not at all an
outrage crazed maniac yeah we uh you
know i'll talk with other hosts of shows
like mine and we'll talk about kind of
like the
tone and tenor of the hate mail and the
antagonistic comments that we get and
everybody else says to me
they are regularly shocked by the focus
on judaism in the messages that i get
um
it'd be interesting to talk sam cedar i
don't want to speak out of turn but sam
has at least suggested that he doesn't
get nearly as much anti-semitic stuff as
i do even though sam is jewish and i
don't know what that's about uh but in
speaking with like jenk yuger from the
young turks we've talked about it also
you know he he gets stuff based on him
being quote muslim or turkish
um and i get a lot of anti-semitic stuff
and a lot of go back to mexico go back
to venezuela stuff even though i'm i'm
from argentina that's another thing and
yeah there's often it's not only about
it's not only about stereotypes it's
also about ignorance as to to whom do
those stereotypes even apply like i'm
from argentina why would i go back to
venezuela i've never even been there
next message is from ronda
ronda says yeah dave speaking of which
yeah david you do look like maybe you
are jewish
i know several latins that are
fair-skinned
and look jewish well thank you rhonda
for defending that i could be both
hispanic and jewish now a lot of people
don't know
that argentina
is a very white country it's not i'm not
giving my opinion of whether that's good
or bad you know there's lots of white
supremacists who ended up not nazi types
who ended up in argentina after world
war ii and a lot of of jewish refugees
who ended up in argentina i'm just
saying there's a lot of what we would
consider white people in argentina
that's a fact
not an opinion but thank you rhonda all
right into some more substantive stuff
john says david have you thought about
adding a co-host to your show don't get
me wrong i love your show and enjoy
listening to it just like it is and i
also like the guest hosts when you're on
vacation like farron and jesse but i
like the young turks too
because it's fun listening to multiple
hosts bouncing ideas and opinions off
each other on the topic being discussed
just an idea so here's the thing with
this
you can always change your show
to be more like a different show
and at one point in the past we had not
really co-hosts but we would we would
sometimes have you know like producers
would weigh in or whatever
not every show can be the same so this
show
doesn't have co-hosts and that's what
this show is if people only like shows
with co-hosts
those shows exist
but my view is not every show has to be
the same so this show is it's just me
giving my thoughts and we have callers
and we have other things there are other
shows with co-hosts
and no audience participation there are
also shows that do a little bit of both
every show is different there's a show
out there for everyone
but this is how our show is set up for
the time being
nicholas wrote in about the rnc
withdrawing from the commission on
presidential debate something we talked
about previously as well as earlier this
week nicholas said hear me out
have a debate
that's just a democrat and a third party
imagine if you had biden or some
democrat and justin amash debating
and just left republicans out of it the
rnc would be like no you weren't
supposed to do that and it would be
amazing yeah i've been thinking about
this a lot and this even came up on our
bonus show discussion earlier this week
about republicans seemingly bailing on
presidential debates
the idea of republicans is to
delegitimize or delegitimate
whoa
the presidential debates
by saying
they are biased and the commission on
presidential debates is partisan and
we're just getting out and they're
imagining of course that that would
leave only the democratic nominee and
that there would just be no debates
whatsoever
it is true
that if you had you know i've always
said i want third parties to have more
of a presence in american politics if
you had a stronger third party candidate
or multiple candidates
and
the commission organized
legitimate debates
where you had the democratic nominee as
well as those third party candidates
it might make the rnc lose their mind
that's absolutely true
the risk of course is
that
because there's no republican in the
presidential debates
very few republicans even watch it you
have a democrat with a couple of
third-party candidates and all it serves
to do
is to siphon off some voters from the
democratic candidate to those
third-party candidates so i think it is
not a strategy without risk it would
absolutely trigger republicans to be
left out for sure
it might be to their benefit and so i
think it has to be thought through
very carefully
harb wrote in with an idea
for a different five-day work week now
we've been talking a lot about the
four-day work week the four-day work
week the idea is you have a four-day
work week and a three-day weekend every
week you do a little bit of adjustment
of hours you do a little bit of
adjustment of expectations and you sort
of like more or less get the same amount
of work done in information type jobs
knowledge jobs this doesn't work when
it's about a retail store being open as
you would in a five-day work week harb
has a different idea
which is a five-day work week
which is
three days on two days off so the
weekends move and the idea would be you
do three 10-hour days and then you get
two days off
and then you get another three ten hour
days and then you get two days off so
the two days off shift throughout the
week it's a little complicated but the
idea is
that you end up working
a little more each year
but you also have more days off each
year and this will allow people to have
both weekdays off and weekends off i
think it's really interesting and
there's a lot of sense in it and i've
heard proposals like this before
the difficulty is it does become a
nightmare
for child care it becomes a nightmare
for a lot of different things where you
have to know okay if i'm making a
doctor's appointment for six months in
advance is this the week where i have
wednesday and thursday off or is this
the week where i have saturday and
sunday off so there's a lot of
complexities to it that's not a reason
not to do it but it seems very difficult
to imagine that the working world at
large is going to be interested in such
a proposal but i find all of these
things super interesting
cher wrote in about dr phil
now here i have to say i misspoke on the
show last week okay
cher wrote in and said hey david it is
incorrect to say dr phil isn't a real
doctor well first of all i didn't say
that okay but i'm going to read the
email as is and then i'll issue my
correction it's incorrect that dr phil
isn't a real doctor he has a ba in
psychology he got his master's in
experimental psychology and a phd in
clinical psychology at north texas state
university
he stopped renewing his license in 2006
he is a retired doctor of psychology
so i wrong i i misremembered
dr phil
is
a psychologist
he is not a medical doctor
and he does not have an active license i
wrongly said he was not a psychologist i
was wrong when i said that it the
segment had nothing to do with dr phil
fortunately it was just sort of like an
aside but i misspoke
he has not renewed his license he
doesn't have an active license
jose wrote in about rumble saying hey
david i wanted updates on why you
haven't uploaded videos to rumble
recently i think it's good to try and
grow an audience where left-wing content
is off almost non-existent yeah we
continue putting up our content on
rumble which is the right wing
video platform there was about a 10-day
period
where rumble wasn't publishing our
videos there was some kind of glitch
we didn't stop they fixed it
now i don't know how much longer the
rumble experiment is going to go on
um we only have like a thousand
subscribers there after a couple months
it it doesn't seem there's a big
appetite for left-wing content on rumble
it doesn't really hurt us in any way to
leave the content up but we're thinking
about okay we tried it and there's not
much of an appetite maybe we'll leave
the content up maybe we won't
lastly today catherine rhoden about my
pillow
catherine says did you see the consumer
reports ratings for my pillow the
quality is mediocre at best
i think consumer reports really tried to
be nice about it but they are paid truth
tellers my mother bought a few about
seven years ago she was addicted to tv
sales pitches and it was the worst
pillow i ever tried to sleep on the
lumpiness was annoying and uncomfortable
it just didn't work for me it was
nothing more than chopped up foam
personally i love a good quality down
pillow yeah so two things one i have
never owned any my pillow products but
many of you have written in most of you
say that they're not good every once in
a while i'll get an email from someone
says guys i hate mike lindell as much as
anybody he's a loon but the pillows are
good so conflicting reports generally
negative i have stopped talking about
down pillows on my show because every
time i say i like a good down pillow
people write in and say david those are
cruel
uh the goose feathers and the duck
feathers etc so catherine
it's great that you're enjoying a down
pillow
i no longer talk about my pillows
because it's become too contentious with
my own audience all right you can write
in info
davidpakman.com send me your questions
comments etc we have a great bonus show
coming up for you today every day
every day we do an extra show
for our members
sign up at joinpakman.com you'll get
instant access
to the bonus show
and you can now gift memberships we have
a backlog of about 700 people who want a
membership but can't afford one
you can check out check the box that
says this is a gift and we will give
your membership to someone in need
we will see you then
you